hello everyone it is I Bremen Rock and
these are my favorite snacks
the first snack we have is pillows these
are my favorite chocolate snacks these
are chocolate filled crackers obviously
if you guys grew up in the Philippines
you guys would know that every Saturday
store has these and they're like five
pesos each I just was always obsessed
with these but the packaging is giving
very much American I know they bought
this in America because the packaging in
the Philippines is not this pristine
this is like luxurious pillows girl
y'all got money in America
[Music]
foreign
cheap chocolate like my favorite I love
this
my favorite thing to do is like let it
melt in my mouth if you actually get the
ones from the Philippines it comes with
like 15 pieces at most so [__] I will
be saving that [__] up like I leave that
[__] in my mouth like
and let it melt you know real pobrecito
get things next snack
Amelia toss it hard girl
the next snack we have is piatos this is
a sour cream and onion
foreign
my favorite thing about Filipinos and
their snacks is that they really flavor
that [__] the snacks I got in America
they're playing y'all short like that's
why my favorite part about the snack is
actually the fingers you get to like
after and yeah I am a snack finger
licking [__] judge me
why am I yelling at the camera I'm so
sorry I'm not yelling at you I'm yelling
through you
boy is next
this is the Filipino popcorn that's what
I would call it these are corn snacks
actually I know it's nothing new I know
America has like corn snacks
surprisingly enough and I know some of
y'all gonna be like [__] how the [__] I
never had popcorn until I moved to
America for the beginning stage of my
life I was convinced that this was
popcorn I still am very much a Boy by
one [__] fair warning though this do
make your breath stink so it is garlic
flavor at the end of the day but like
it's super garlicky so if you're going
on a date with a Vampire don't kiss him
next because I can smell my breath from
here you know that one scene in
SpongeBob where they had the Krabby
Patties and it made everybody's breath
stink and like it had like the green
smell can you edit that in
thank you hit me girl
ah period
[Applause]
we got Chuck nut up in this [__] kill
this is one of my favorite snacks when
my mom goes home I always tell her to
get the Chuck knot because the Chuck nut
they make in the Philippines is so
different from the one you get in
America but that's neither here nor
there there's this cute little game that
we play
and I know I know Mexicans do this with
marzipan as well where they start to
open it without messing it up to be
honest I feel like I haven't been
describing what they taste like I've
just been talking about it this one
tastes just like how it sounds it tastes
like chocolate with peanuts let's try to
open it without messing it off
this one already came broken oh my gosh
I'm disqualified already let me try open
one more time I can't talk my [__] and
break it if you can open this without
breaking you can perform open heart
surgery Rumor Has It
thank you thank you the audience Goes
Wild
[Applause]
that went right straight to the cavities
I could feel that in my cavity girl
[Music]
that was so naimasu
not imas is amazing or Oishi or
delicious or that [__] was busting not
imas and a i
Mas I think that was your ilocano word
of the day
skyflakes yeah if you're a mother and
you always have like emergency snacks
for your kids in your bag this is
definitely one of them this one is the
filled ones which I really enjoy as well
I believe this is the one with condensed
milk flavored ones
um this is often enjoyed with coffee
this is like kind of like an old people
thing
yes also this is served in a lot of
funerals and I don't know why but like
specifically somehow the condesada
flavored one
is what they always serve at the [__]
funerals and that's the first thing I
thought of I don't know why it's
bringing me back to
my uncle's funeral
okay this video is getting really dark
so yeah
Love Funeral food cute this is the
Philippine mango now there's multiple
brands that make this this is the one
that we found and the steaks are high
because I've never seen this brand
before and I'm very particular with my
mango so they better have used
Philippine mango [__] or somebody
it's getting the chop I'm kidding okay
no but literally if you guys have never
had Philippine mango in your life then
don't be walking around that you ate the
best mango ever because [__] Filipino
is the best mango and I will die on that
[__] Hill
let's taste if this is a real Philippine
mango
okay you're good you're good girl you're
good
wow
this is made out of the Philippine mango
thank God this Max reminds me of like
all the road trips to Manila
that we would have but I think they sell
this a lot in Baguio City pretty sure
that's where I first had it thank you
guys for this honestly like not to get
really deep right now but like every
snack has taken me back in a really cute
place this is Mariani Philippine mango I
recommend this brand this is Filipino
approved
I had so much fun reminiscing of my
favorite childhood snack it definitely
told me to go back home in the
Philippines as soon as I can because now
I miss home speaking of I have a book
coming out you guys it is titled none
other than your that [__] it's coming
out Valentine's Day you guys can get it
in any stores where you buy books Barnes
Noble Tarjay Amazon anywhere I love you
guys and I will see you later aloha
buy my book
[Music]